hello and welcome to this video play
uptown girl yeah played him probably
still and just recently don't remember
what that was and okay we got a Tory
attack and go ahead and play quickly him
and we have two should a sixth like to
prevent okay we cannot sacrifice right
as I was going to get seven so it
doesn't work there should be six ft
screen takes rook f7 could have played
night h5 actually hmm I should have also
okay I can go be five now expand a
little bit on the on the queenside like
to get the bishop there but just go as a
special each form so this is also pretty
okay maybe now right if if he goes
Bishop age for I have night f for the
night only three that looks a little bit
more attractive okay I'm happy to check
the bishop pal why not so ya can go a
five-year you even though that opens up
his bishop but I can let's first improve
them Bishop here a little bit
here also Bishop g7 route 88 centralized
a little bit more it's not quite clear
what he is doing on this one okay
where are you going with this okay I'm
think I'm I'm doing this trying to trade
is not trading
you
maybe I can get a five before yeah it
would be really helpful if I would
weekly understand what this is all about
can also just come on play 45m if he's
shuffling around his his stuff here I'm
going to open it up okay maybe just back
always there anything but I am that's
probably okay
yeah of course a you can just do that
but again I'm kicking him back and
spending the the biggest danger against
these kind of players who just shuffle
around without any particular purpose is
to you try to do something and then you
get get time term issues I mean it's
mostly just shuffling around and doing
not much if you try to refute it in an
entirely then you're often check will
pay with the chat with time issues so
I'm just getting this good end game now
and see what I can do and can do from
here Bishop goes around King f2 is cool
Bishop c5 okay before and some
weaknesses there
let let me let me think about this for
just a moment damn what is the best way
to do that Bishop the tool takes
Teague's I will yeah I'm ship t2 is good
check okay so what now f4 maybe yeah I
want to limit that limit that annoyed
nidus dominated by the bishop okay so
he's shooting for b6
this is this is actually precise draw
our third am this is this is winning so
that the bishop can go back to e5
might be one maybe to continue um so c3i
okay easiest assign one to just take it
first and then see from here I think I
can go up to be three we should be three
check and c 3 c 2 is so not easy to
prevent
check
check it's not super exciting but what
can you do white resign assume name yeah
it there wasn't he in yeah I'm sorry I
probably get comments about that but
it's just basically shuffling around
without any particular idea and main
thing is you have to be be quite quick
so that you don't lose on time and keep
your slide advantages like here with
them with the two bishops and term you
know it is slightly better for black but
it's nothing particularly oh yeah it's
not winning or anything f5 is probably
probably good but I wanted to as I said
in the commentary be quick about it can
check I got this great endgame which she
immediately I mean it is bad for white
anyway but he immediately turned it into
a loss after after after before after
before white is completely losing it was
played immediately almost and it's quite
clear that is lost because those two
points are not going to be a going to be
held he has to has to stay put here with
93 which is of course a big torture but
it's what he has to do my majority has
far more dangerous and have easy ideas
centralizing the king and pushing the
points forward and get yet this is just
a loss chan and foyer so that 93 c4 is
not getting them horn back yeah that's a
really pretty clear-cut Shaq cleare
catalyst yeah it's against those those
clean porn openings sometimes people
play it with some ambition okay that's
good but sometimes they just want to
shuffle around and do nothing and
against those you have to be M you have
to have some patience
it's not so easy to get something
quickly something concrete but I'm just
trying to yeah get something that is a
little bit better yeah having the bishop
pair or some slight edges and then try
to be quick is the best strategy which
sometimes I'm not getting yeah I'm just
thinking too long trying to get more
more MORE instead of him playing a small
advantage um quickly I think I did this
quite okay in this game and when it was
done on time anyway but it wasn't to
some dramatic proportion and it was
relatively easy to play okay thanks for
watching